Wilbur and Orville Wright did everything together.
They started a local newspaper together.
Opened a bike shop together.
And they invented the first airplane together.
They were so in sync that
Wilbur said they “thought
together”...but they also “fought together”.
They argued A LOT. The bickering
would often start at breakfast
The bickering would often start at breakfast,
carry on through lunch, and continue past dinner.
Once, a quarrel became so intense
that their sister Katharine cried out,
“If you don’t stop arguing, I’ll leave home!”
Standing up for themselves was
encouraged in their childhood.
Their father, Milton Wright, was a bishop,
but he included books by atheists and
agnostics in his library and encouraged
his children to read and debate them.
Debating helped them develop the
courage to fight for their ideas.
If they hadn’t, the airplane
might never have been invented.
In the early days of aviation, the very idea
of human flight was considered impossible.
The Washington Post declared at the turn of the
20th century: “It is a fact that man can’t fly.”
Many attempted controlled flight
but none had succeeded.
In 1896, German aviator Otto Lilienthal lost
his life when he lost control of his glider
due to a sudden gust of wind.
His technique of adjusting the
machine's center of gravity by shifting
his body proved impractical and dangerous.
Despite no college education
or technical training,
the Wright brothers dared to dream
of flight, with Orville saying:
“We could not understand that there was
anything about a bird that would enable
it to fly that could not be built
on a larger scale and used by man.”
One of their most intense arguments had
to do with the design of the propeller.
In the early 20th century,
there were no existing models.
Most of what they knew came
from their knowledge of boats,
but a propeller designed for the water
didn’t work efficiently in the air.
They needed a narrower blade with a higher speed.
With no existing designs to work from, they
had to invent the propeller themselves.
They argued over the propeller’s speed,
the precise angle at which the blades strike
the air, the velocity of their flying machine,
and how airflow around the propeller
blades affects aerodynamics.
All of these elements were
deeply interconnected and
challenged them to engineer the ideal propeller.
Wilbur, the older brother, was
highly disagreeable and didn’t
care much about what other people thought of him.
Orville, on the other hand, was gentle and
sensitive to criticism but wasn’t afraid to punch
back when it came to his older brother. Wilbur
even exclaimed, “He’s such a good scrapper.”
Author John McMahon, who wrote a
book about the Wright brothers,
described their intense debates this way:
“Their low staccato voices sounded like muffled
machine guns in the low-ceilinged living room
of their home and in the little bedrooms
upstairs, where they continued to hurl angles,
sines, cosines and tangents at each
other through the thin partitions.”
Sometimes, these debates
escalated into shouting matches.
Their bike mechanic Charlie Taylor who helped
build the engines for their planes, observed:
“They'd shout at each other something terrible. I
don't think they really got mad,
but they sure got awfully hot.”
Yet, they never attacked each
other personally but rather
focused on challenging each other’s viewpoints.
They’d even find themselves persuading each
other and then both changing their minds.
Orville recalled: “...we would discover that we
were as far from agreement as when we started,
but that both had changed to the other's
original position in the discussion.”
After months of debate, the Wright
brothers finally understood that
a propeller works like a rotating wing.
When the propellers spin and push air backward,
it creates a force called thrust,
which pushes the airplane forward.
This is based on Newton's third law of motion,
which says that for every action,
there's an equal and opposite reaction.
They eventually figured out that
the plane needed not one propeller,
but two spinning in opposite directions.
The spinning of one would balance out the
other… making the plane easier to control.
They made the propellers out of wood,
cutting them to the right size and
shape using a hatchet and drawshave.
They then decided to put them
to the test at Kitty Hawk,
a small fishing village in North
Carolina known for its strong winds.
When they had to decide who would attempt
the first flight on December 14, 1903,
they avoided another argument
in this case by tossing a coin.
Wilbur won.
But he lost the chance to be the first
to fly successfully when he oversteered,
causing the aircraft to climb too
steeply, stall, and dive into the sand.
After repairing the Flyer, they made
a second attempt three days later.
With Orville in the pilot’s seat, the
flyer stayed in the air for 12 seconds,
traveling 120 ft or 37 meters.
When Orville was later asked if he was scared,
he responded: “Scared? There wasn’t time.”
They flew four times that day.
The fourth and final attempt – this
time with Wilbur at the controls - was
the best flight, lasting 59 seconds
and covering 852 feet (260 meters).
They had taught the world that humans could fly.
But they didn’t really celebrate.
For them, it was business as usual.
Their mechanic, Charlie Taylor, captured
their understated reaction perfectly:
“I know I thought it was pretty nice that they
had done what they set out to do, and I was glad
to hear that the motor ran all right. But
I don't remember doing any jig steps. The
boys were always so matter-of-fact about things,
and they never made an effort to get me excited.
Even when they got home, there was no
special celebration in the shop. Of
course they were pleased with the flights.
But their first word with me, as I remember,
was about the motor being damaged…They were
always thinking of the next thing to do…”
Just as their arguments were never about
personally attacking each other but about
making their planes better, they didn’t celebrate
but instead, focused on improving their aircraft.
Now they had to prove they could fully
control their plane by turning and flying
longer distances as their flights up to
then were short and in a straight line.
Luckily, the owner of a cow pasture a few
miles outside of their hometown of Dayton,
Ohio, kindly let them fly there so they didn’t
have to make the long trek to Kitty Hawk.
In 1904 and 1905, the Wright
brothers made about 150 flights.
One lasted 39 minutes,
covering 24.5 miles or 39 km,
during which Wilbur circled the field 29 times.
When it was time to show the world
their invention, the French aviator
Léon Delagrange summed up the superiority
of the Wright flying machine this way:
“Nous sommes battus”, meaning, “We are beaten.”
Their rigorous debates propelled the
Wright brothers to conquer the skies.
As Wilbur once said: “Discussion brings
out new ways of looking at things.”
If the Wright brothers hadn’t argued so
much, they would never have pushed each
other to try new things, and somebody else
may have ended up in the history books.
Their dedication and knowledge in math and physics
led to the world’s first functional airplane.
If you've been inspired to build a strong
foundation in STEM, Brilliant is a great resource
to learn math, science, computer science, and data
science interactively, and it’s FREE to try out.
Whether you're starting with the basics in
math or tackling more advanced problems,
Brilliant guides you every step of the way.
Many of their interactive courses are
designed to tackle real-world challenges.
Take Brilliant's new Thinking in Code
course, which gets you designing simple
programs to solve real-world problems
like creating a navigation app.
You can try out Brilliant for FREE for 30 days by
signing up with the custom link in my
description: brilliant.org/newsthink.
And if you’re one of the first 200 people to
sign up with my link, you’ll receive 20% off
Brilliant’s Premium subscription, which gives you
access to all of their thousands of offerings.
Thanks for watching. For Newsthink, I’m Cindy Pom.